hey guys welcome to this fourth edition
of my hair academia recap where I
explain something from the series in
about two to five minutes now as most of
you know I don't usually make comments
on individual chapters as I prefer to
talk about arcs as a whole rather than
just one part of it
however today horikoshi did something
that left me with virtually no other
choice as chapter 265 of the manga has
changed the game people now for clarity
the full chapter hasn't come out yet but
what we do have is about ten pages of
untranslated spoilers that leaked so
when the official release comes out
there will be more to it and at the end
of the video I'll tell you guys how you
can read the official release on Sunday
and how I typically read the manga as
well but with that said let's dive
straight into the spoilers so starting
with the main take up from this thing
the reason why I'm making this video we
got this awesome spread of Hawks using
his quark against twice to take down a
bunch of clones as the real twice
watches on with tears in his eyes still
visibly upset at the fact that Hawkes
betrayed him on a side note I'm kind of
unsure how Hawkes believed that he'd be
able to take twice of the police without
needing to knock him out or even kill
him I mean the guy has infinite doubles
he can activate it whenever he wants so
once again he's been underestimated not
from the league's we then see that
daddy's blue flames engulf Hawks
literally dobby comes out of nowhere and
in the center of his flames we can see
hawks his hair and what hooks is likely
still alive at this point it's highly
likely that all of his feathers that he
was just using to attack twice have been
eviscerated that's my educated guess as
it makes sense that dobby would do this
it's also possible that these flames
burnt the remaining wings that were in
Hawks is back as well because when we
look at this panel again just before he
attacks hawks Hawks barely has any wings
left to begin with this has strong
parallels with the story of Icarus who
was a character in Greek mythology but
used a pair of wax wings but flew too
close to the Sun and his wings
eventually melted away where he then
fell into the ocean and died now in
hawks his case he metaphorically flew
too close to the Sun by getting in too
deep with the paranormal Liberation
Front and it seems that trying to take
down twice was just one step too far not
only does it seem that his wings have
now melted away but Dobby then steps on
his head and sets his leg on fire I'll
repeat that
Dobby puts his foot on hawks his head
and then he ignites his leg Hawks
doesn't have any like fire proof powers
guys like he's not fire
so what Debbie's doing right now could
be fatal this could genuinely kill him I
know it would kill me if Hawks somehow
manages to survive this encounter and I
really hope he does because he's one of
my favorite characters but if he
survives it's gonna be a miracle I'm
hoping that he maybe has one feather
that just like didn't get burnt up in
the attack and then potentially it takes
out Dobby or but even if it does twice
is still right there so and you're not
gonna defeat an army of twice Clemens
with one feather
so yeah Hawks is really in an impossible
situation right now the only way I
realistically see him making it out of
this is if the heroes manage to get to
him in time and we did see that taki
army is in the mansion and did have a
thought about hawks so perhaps they can
reach him in time but with that said I
mean Hawks is seemingly being set on
fire as we speak Dobby is yeah I don't
see how they're gonna do it to be honest
as I said you guys know Hawks is one of
my favorite characters so I'm gonna be
genuinely inconsolable if he actually
dies the next chapter I do remember the
horikoshi said awhile ago and I can't
remember wearing exactly this quote was
from but he did say the Hawks were
specifically put in the story because he
needed a certain character to fulfill a
certain role like do a certain thing so
so it's possible that when that thing
the horikoshi she's talking about when
that was completed then that character
would just they could die because
they've served their purpose I don't
know if that's the case but I mean he
did definitely say that anyway enough
doom and gloom there were a few cool
things that came out of these leaks so
we got to see Tamaki demonstrate some
cool new animal abilities so this time
he has the legs of a horse and is
galloping through the paranormal
Liberation Front mansion and he also has
these cool horns on his head I love this
guy because you never know what to
expect from him his quirk is truly like
a jack-of-all-trades type work you just
you can do anything but the thing that
really surprised me about this chapter
right this took me out cuz I generally
wasn't expecting this now toki ami is
obviously a very powerful student and as
quark is opie like it's really strong
but I did not expect him to be able to
take down Reed Astro because for those
of you that have read them either than
academia arc which if you're watching
this video I'm gonna kind of assume you
have then the way we just wrote is
presented is very much as a boss level
villain right like Yashica rocky was
able to defeat him but that's only
because shigga rocky himself is like
basically the next all for one but Reed
Astra was so powerful so the fact that a
student at school was able to defeat him
this just shows how strong dark shadow
truly
so from these blurry images it seems
like toki army and rajesh trio go
head-to-head
until registros prosthetic leg gives way
and then he sent flying backwards it
would be interesting to see how the
fight would have gone had read Astro not
had his legs decayed by shigaraki but
you know fair play to Tokyo army still
he can only beat what's in front of him
and he did beat me destro so fair play
to him but for the purposes of this
recap that's everything that I wanted to
talk about from these pages I think it's
also worth noting that a sun-eater was
throwing around pineapples for some
reason I guess he can manifest fruit as
well or maybe maybe brought that along
with them I don't know but yeah the full
official release of this chapter should
come out on Sunday and if you're
interested in reading the manga what I
personally do is I subscribe to the
Shonen Jump app for 2 pounds a month and
if it's possible to get that depending
on where you live then I would recommend
it however if it's not available where
you live then another thing that I've
heard is good is Mango Plus I've never
used it myself but I hear it's a
substitute for the Shonen Jump app so do
be sure to check that out as well what I
typically do is read the spoilers when
they come out and then I'll read the
obviously the full official translation
when that comes out as well because
these spoilers I'm looking at they're
not even translated bro so I don't even
know what they're saying I'm just going
off the images here but I just wanted to
give my thoughts in it my quick reaction
I mean I just can't believe what's
happening with Hawks I really hope it
makes out of this alive I'm gonna be
really upset guys I'm gonna be really
upset if he does oh and by the way I
probably have a new list video coming
out I recorded it and everything is one
of my fact no I think it's the favorite
one I've done so far but editing takes a
long time guys so I'm hoping I'll get it
out Saturday or Sunday turn
notifications so that you'll get
notified when I post it because I truly
think it is my best one yet
catch you guys next time peace out